هل تجعلك هذه الأصوات تشعر بوخز في
رأسك ورقبتك ،
ما قد
تواجهه يسمى asmr ، فهو يمثل
استجابة خط الطول الحسية المستقلة أو ببساطة
وجود إحساس بالوخز المريح
استجابةً للمحفزات الصوتية والمرئية
مثل النقر المتجعد
والبطء المتعمد  الحركات
في السنوات الأخيرة أصبحت مقاطع الفيديو
asmr ظاهرة على الإنترنت حصدت
الملايين من ملايين المشاهدات ،
وهناك فوائد لمشاهدة
مقاطع الفيديو asmr خاصة إذا كنت شخصًا
يمكنه تجربة الوخزات asmr ، مرحباً
بالجميع
اليوم سأقوم بعمل مقطع فيديو
دائمًا ما يطلب الأشخاص بشدة
أن asmr تشبه النشوة وتقريباً
منومة مغناطيسية ، لذا قد يكون asmr
يعمل لأنه يتسبب في
حالة من النوع التأملي في المشاهدين
في بحثنا ، حيث كانت التخفيضات التي
وجدناها في معدل ضربات القلب عندما شاهد الأشخاص
مقاطع فيديو asmr  يمكن مقارنتها
بالتدخلات الأخرى لتقليل القلق
مثل اليقظة والموسيقى المعتمدة
على أبحاث الحد من التوتر  لا تزال فوائد مقاطع فيديو asmr
في مراحلها الأولية
إذا لم تواجه أي شيء مميز بعد
مشاهدة مقاطع فيديو مثل هذه ، فأنت لست
وحدك
وليس كل شخص يعاني من asmr في الواقع ،
قد يجد بعض الأشخاص هذه الأصوات
مزعجة
ولكن إذا كنت ترغب في منحها
حاول البحث عن مقاطع الفيديو التي تعرض
مشغلات asmr الشائعة مثل
تمزيق الورق الناعم
والمضغ
وطنين
الشعر بالفرشاة
والماء المتساقط
أو عن قرب الانتباه الشخصي في يوم عصيب جدًا ،
نعم
يمكنني معرفة نوع الفيديو الذي قد
يتضمن كل هذه الأشياء يمكن أن يكون قصة
شعر محاكاة
أريدك  إن تبليل بعض محفزات شعرك
يمكن أن يكون مرئيًا مثل
مشاهدة شخص ما يطوي منشفة
بحذر شديد أو يرضي بشكل غريب
محفزات بصرية مثل اللعب
بالوحل ونعلم من بحثنا أن
الأشخاص يظهرون انخفاضًا في معدل ضربات
القلب بعد مشاهدة asmr لمدة ثلاث
دقائق تقريبًا  أثناء استكشافك للمحفزات المحتملة ،
ضع في اعتبارك أن الخبراء يقولون إن
مقاطع فيديو asmr ليست بديلاً عن مساعدة
الطبيب  أو المعالج ،
ما أود قوله هو أنه
يمكن استخدام مقاطع الفيديو هذه
كمكمل للأشياء التي تقوم بها بالفعل
إذا كنت مهتمًا بمعرفة
ما إذا كان يمكن أن يساعدك على النوم أو
تخفيف القلق ، فهذا بالتأكيد
شيء يمكنك تجربته
[  تصفيق]
[موسيقى]